y hablamos ahora de salud del directo
américa de france 24 y ya me acompaña
como esa costumbre más romeros a la mar
bienvenida ya estamos a viernes y vamos
a hablar de china seguimos en asia hay
un repunte de casos de kobe 19 porque
márquez sabemos de esta situación pues
ha habido una preocupación general desde
hace unas semanas por este rebrote de
casos de cuba en china mayoritariamente
empujados por la variante o micro en
repasemos bien las cifras para saber de
qué estamos hablando vemos que los casos
diarios sobre todo en estas últimas
semanas han llegado a puntear alrededor
de los 4.000 casos aunque lo que nos da
más información en realidad es el
promedio de 7 días no la línea
anaranjada es de ese promedio de este
último rebrote y si lo comparamos con la
línea amarilla que fue el rebrote de
wuhan de hace poco más de dos años del
entre enero y febrero de 2020 vemos que
todavía no está alcanzando las
dimensiones de ese brote que nos asustó
tanto en 2020 al inicio de la pandemia
aunque si bien es cierto sí es cierto
raúl que es el rebrote más alto de casos
que ha habido desde ese momento desde
2020 pero a lo mejor no tan mortal no y
bueno llegó la guerra y por supuesto ya
19 como que pasa un lado sin olvidar que
pues todavía estamos en medio de esta
pandemia pero qué medidas se están
aplicando para luchar contra esta
emergencia sanitaria mar pues la verdad
es que china ha sido muy constante en
sus políticas contra la pandemia de kobe
19 desde ese enclaustramiento masivo que
hubo en wuhan en el 2020 no han habido
muchos cambios seguimos con cierres
totales de fronteras con aislamientos
para todos los casos positivos y también
para sus contactos cercanos incluso hay
centros de aislamiento dedicados
particularmente a esos testigos masivos
a toda la población y también
restricciones de movimiento cuando hace
falta lo hemos visto en la provincia de
jilín que estuvo pues sin la posibilidad
de salir de ahí durante varias varios
días en la ciudad de shenzhen también
estuvo confinada y estudiar a lo que
temer en shanghai que también podría ser
que suceda aunque por ahora los
aislamientos son concretos son en
ciudades y barrios residenciales todo
esto se resume a una política que han
llamado covite cero dinámico es decir de
tratar del minar el virus del cob y 19
aunque esta vez pues siendo un poco más
flexibles en las políticas que pueden
aplicar las autoridades locales y
también tratando de minimizar el impacto
de la pandemia en la sociedad y en la
economía ahora a marc como se vio este
tipo de políticas desde la población
china es interesante saberlo porque
asumimos que quizás deben estar muy
frustrados o muy cansados pero entonces
para entender mejor esto le pedimos a
adrián foncillas que es el corresponsal
de france 24 en beijing que nos contará
cómo se vive desde ahí
la población es ángel se apresura estos
días a comprar víveres en previsión de
otro confinamiento masivo han pasado más
de dos años desde aquel inédito
cerrojazo en luján y china sigue fiel a
la receta nadie le discute aquí porque
funciona evitado las grandes mortandades
del resto del mundo y ha protegido la
economía porque dos o tres semanas de
parón localizado tienen menos efectos
perjudiciales que ese continuo ciclo de
aperturas y cierres aquí se ensalza la
capacidad de sacrificio la disciplina
frente a cómo ha lidiado a occidente con
la pandemia desde el inicio las
comparaciones con la gripe los debates
sobre las mascarillas las
manifestaciones cuando el virus estaba
ya extendido o la teoría de la inmunidad
de rebaño cuando aún se carecía de
vacunas ha habido algunas protestas aquí
por ejemplo en xian pero no fue por la
decisión en sí del encierro sino por la
incapacidad de las autoridades de llevar
alimentos a los confinados es paradójico
que haya habido más disensiones en la
clase científica que entre la población
algunos científicos
y han defendido que china debería
jubilar su política de 'tolerancia cero'
y aprender a convivir con el virus
especialmente ahora con una tasa de
vacunación cercana al 90 por ciento y
con variantes tan contagiosas como
omicron china ha desoído esas voces y se
ha mantenido fiel a esa receta sabedora
de que si la cambiar a las primeras
críticas le llegarían desde su propia
población nuestro corresponsal en
beijing mar pero ahora cómo se comparan
estos rebrotes de kobe 19 en china con
el resto del mundo pues veamos adrián
estamos escuchando que decía que la
población china de hecho estaba
mayoritariamente apoyando este tipo de
medidas porque habían funcionado y la
verdad es que si medimos lo que funciona
o no con los parámetros del número de
casos y de número de muertes podemos
decir que algo de razón tienen las
cifras de contagios y de muertes por
ccoo y 19 en china están a años luz de
las de países por ejemplo con estados
como eeuu o brasil y esto que llamamos
rebrote es muy relativo y de hecho
palidece cuando lo comparamos con las
cifras de otros países en el mundo aquí
tienen las cifras de los promedios
semanales la fecha de 23 de marzo vemos
son unos 2.000 casos de promedio diarios
en china pero es que en eeuu son 30.000
en brasil son 35.000 en reino unido- y
en francia superan los 100 mil en
vietnam por ejemplo un país con una
población muchísimo menor que la de
china estamos en un promedio de casos
diarios de 200.000 es muy importante
tener esta perspectiva porque hay mucha
crítica internacional hacia pues estas
políticas de kobe 0 que implementa china
que además es el único país ya se han
quedado solos en esta manera de afrontar
el commit 19 pero en realidad pues vemos
que algún efecto si ha tenido aunque la
verdad es posible lo adelantamos ahora
pero tocará que lo sigamos en las
próximas semanas que haya algunas voces
de cambio que ya se están pronunciando
pues para intentar cambiar estas medidas
y llegar a puntos algo más flexibles
después de dos años de tanta rigurosidad
en el manejo de la pandemia pues más
gracias entonces por toda la información
de salud nos vemos la semana que viene
con más feliz viernes feliz fin de
semana descansar y pasamos a saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado al día
[Música]